I have been tracking the story of the
NRA s role as a sort of conduit between
Russia and the 2016 Trump campaign for
months now and the NRA of course the
National Rifle Association is the
biggest gun lobby in the country and
McClatchy has been following this story
for months and vivica Novak even joined
me to discuss it some time ago and
explain the path through which Russian
money was coming through the NRA and
being used to fund Donald Trump's
campaign and last week we learned about
Russian agent Maria abou Tina and she
was in the United States working for
Russian interests without registering as
a foreign agent she has now been
indicted and this I told you last week
and in the days since we found out that
one of the organizations that she had
infiltrated or was working with
depending on your point of view I guess
is the NRA so the NRA gets caught
red-handed working with a Russian agent
sending millions of dollars to help
Donald Trump's campaign the same day of
Maria boo Tina's indictment a law was
passed to protect the unnamed donors of
the NRA that's the story I can go into
more detail but this is the crux of this
corrupt situation we're in on Monday
last week we learned about Maria boo
Tina's indictment on Tuesday we learned
that the previous night the Treasury
Department had changed a rule which
clarifies that information on donors who
give $5,000 or more to organizations
like the NRA does not have to be given
to the IRS and we're also getting more
information about the specifics of what
Maria boo Tina was trying to do through
the NRA and lo and behold huge shocker
her goal was to try to use the NRA to
influence the Republican Party to be
friendlier towards Russia which is
exactly what the Republican Party has
been doing since Donald Trump was
elected and if you're wondering how much
influence their NRA actually has on our
elected officials beyond just what's
going on with Donald Trump of the 535
current members of Congress
meaning the hundred senators and 435
representatives 307 307 out of 535 are
almost 60% either received direct
contributions from the NRA or benefited
from NRA advertising on their behalf of
course in favor of them nearly 60% of
the members of the House and Senate who
benefited from NRA funds likely received
Russian money in so benefiting from the
NRA they aren't even making an effort to
hide it anymore and why would they
because there have really been no
consequences to speak to speak of thus
far maybe there will be at some point
but so far there haven't and what we
actually need right now is the exact
opposite of what this law is we need
laws passed to require more disclosure
of dark money donors more disclosure of
donations to the NRA of the
organizations that take advantage of
nonprofit status and do politics which
they're not supposed to do we're taking
dark money and by we I mean Trump in his
cronies they are taking dark money and
when we learn that hey the dark money
may be connected to illegal outside
contributions for example like through
Russia they make the dark money even
darker when what we need is actually
sunshine to disinfect this malignancy
and Steven minuchin the Treasury
secretary goes in and does the exact
opposite of what we actually need and
this rule change will make figuring out
what actually happened with Booty know
because we don't know yet right we're
gonna make we're gonna have even more
trouble figuring out what did the NRA do
what did boo Tina do what did
Republicans do it's gonna be even more
difficult which is the goal that is why
Steven minuchin is doing this and before
this rule change conceivably at least it
was possible to identify illegal foreign
money given to American elections this
rule change will make it more difficult
and that's what they want so this should
be bigger news sadly but not shockingly
it's not making big news and it just so
happens by the way that Maria boo Tina
not only met with people from the NRA
she also met with
Treasury officials which is the
organization responsible for changing
this rule and that's what I want to talk
about next which is arguably as big or
an even even bigger scandal I'm really
thrilled to tell you that today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman as many of
you know I have been working very hard
on this program to reduce stigma around
mental health to reduce stigma around
seeking help and I have a family that is
very involved in mental health and if
you've not already heard about better
help it is a tremendous resource better
help gives you through your phone and
computer affordable private access to
licensed trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you they are LGBT friendly you can
even say I want a counselor who's not
religious if that's important to you if
your initial match isn't a good vibe you
can switch to a different counselor and
the beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm
PA que ma n